LOCOMOTION is a boon to animals.
We find plants moving, and animals
moving as well as locomoting.
So what’s the basic difference between the
two?
Well, movement is basically just moving a
particular part, while locomotion is
trans-locating from one place to another.
Hence we say that plants only move,
while animals can carry out both, movement
as well as locomotion.
Well, in our previous video, we have seen
how various parts of the body are
connected.
Now let’s have a look as to how animals
locomote, and how the
parts inside our body move!
Wait a second… do parts within us actually
move?
Of course they do!
Although we do not notice the organs inside
us bouncing,
they all move in some or the other manner.
Imagine if one fine day, the
stomach and intestines stop moving…
What would happen then?
Well, it
would be quite bad as the complete digestion
process would stop!
Similarly,
what if our lungs stop contraction and relaxation?
Well, needless to say, that
would cost us our life!
So then, who helps us with these important
processes of movement and
locomotion?
Yes!
It’s the MUSCULAR tissue!
As the name says, muscular
means made up of muscles.
The cells of this tissue are elongated and
contain
contractile proteins.
Now what could be these basically?
Well, when we say
movement, it means the muscles themselves
have to perform contraction and
relaxation right?
So for this, the cells have proteins like
actin and myosin,
which themselves contract or relax, thus enabling
the muscles to do the same.
With this, does this mean that the tissue
will not have types?
Because all
muscles are the same right?
Well, actually not!
Muscles come in various types, depending on
their functions.
So are we trying
to say that muscles in our stomach are different
from those in our biceps?
Of
course yes!
The fact that both serve different functions
itself suggests that
their structure and nature is going to be
different.
So what are the various types of Muscular
tissue?
Well, for simplicity of
understanding, we divide them into three major
categories.
STRIATED Muscles,
SMOOTH muscles, and CARDIAC muscles.
Let’s have a look at each type.
The first one is called STRIATED muscles.
Now as the name suggests, striated,
means when we stain this tissue and observe
it under the microscope, then it
exhibits striations in the form of alternate
light and dark bands.
Where do we
find this type by the way?
We find these striated muscles attached to
the
bones.
Hence they are also named as the SKELETAL
muscles.
Also, when we
say attached to the skeleton, it means they
help in movement of our hands
and legs, along with locomotion.
So can we say that their action is carried
out
according to our will?
Absolutely!
And that is the reason we call them
Voluntary muscles also!
Thus, striated muscles are called as skeletal
muscles
and voluntary muscles as well.
These are found to have a typical cylindrical
structure due to wrapping of the long muscle
fibres together.
These are usually
unbranched and multi-nucleate in nature.
On similar lines, we have the next type that
is ‘smooth muscles’.
These are also
called as UNSTRIATED and INVOLUNTARY.
Now we can guess their structure
and nature from the names itself!
Smooth or unstriated because they do not
present a banding pattern like the striated
ones when stained and observed
under a microscope.
Instead, they have long, spindle shaped, uni-nucleate
cells.
And why involuntary?
Yes!
Because their activities are not under our
control.
So what could be their location now?
Well, we find smooth muscles in the
stomach, in the bronchi, in the uterus and
also in the iris of eyes.
Now let’s take a look at the last type that
is cardiac muscles.
Again, the name is
enough for us to state its function and location.
These muscles are those
found in the heart.
So the rhythmic contraction and relaxation
of our heart, or
the working of our heart, is all because of
these cardiac muscles.
Although they
are involuntary in activity, their structure
is like that of striated muscles
partially.
They are cylindrical and branched, but uni-nucleate
in nature.
These
muscles perform rhythmic contraction and relaxation
tirelessly throughout our
life!
Well, this was about the three major types
of muscular tissues – the striated,
smooth and cardiac!
In the next video we will discuss nervous
tissues in
details.